- When you wanna explore your sexuality
or who you really are on the inside,
your inner demons, basically,
or your inner love piece,
like, all you gotta do is just
really just think about it
and really analyze the whole
thing and it will come out
and it will bring you to a
different level of dark pleasure,
like good pleasure.
- [Mark] All right, Brian.
So, Brian, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- New Jersey. Paterson, New Jersey.
- Paterson. And tell me
about your childhood.
You have both your parents growing up?
- Yes. I did have both my parents.
- How was your childhood?
- My childhood was like
a normal kid, you know.
We played outside after school.
You know, softball, kickball,
stick ball, tree tag, manhunt.
All the good stuff before
the street lights came on.
You know?
- Any craziness in your childhood?
- Yeah, I was molested by my brother, man.
I remembered it my whole life growing up.
- An older brother?
- Yes. And it was kind
of rough for me at first.
When I finally got older and I realized
and it came back to me and I was like,
"Man, what am I? Am I
gay? Am I like bisexual?
What am I? Am I gonna be a serial killer
like the guys from Criminal Mind
or am I gonna be a child molester?"
So I had to dig deep and
find who I really was.
So I experimented.
I've come to find out I'm not fully gay,
but I'm bisexual.
So it's like I like girls more than guys,
but it's because she wants it, not me.
So it's like I don't prefer,
but I like the pleasure.
You know, something I'll share
with the world a little bit.
- What do you do for a living?
- I'm a full-time barber.
Been cutting hair for like 29 years.
I've traveled cutting hair.
And I've also...
I like to mess around
with cars and with stuff.
- So a mechanic?
- Yeah, it's a little mechanic
work. Body work really.
- Okay.
So you like to come down here
and pick up some of the
girls on the street?
- I definitely like to come
pick up some of the girls.
- (laughs)
- Whether they're called prostitutes or
substitutes, or whatever the case may be.
But they're beautiful to me. Beautiful.
- Yeah, some of the girls
are actually really nice.
- Yeah, they're really
nice, man. You know?
Just messed up, the way
other people treat them.
Just because they are what they are,
it doesn't mean you have
to treat them like that.
You gotta flip it around a little bit.
Treat them different than
what the average person would,
you know, because it's rough.
It's rough down here, man.
- It's terrible.
- It's rough, man.
- Yeah. A lot of the
girls have told me stories
about getting raped and beaten.
- Yeah, bad, bad, bad.
- Guns and knives and
all kinds of (mumbles)
- Bad, bad, bad. Not me, man.
I'm more of lover and a fighter.
But I like to love, man. You know?
Some people don't know
what that really means.
Or they did, but then it
got so abused that it's like
now it's hard for them
to trust and to love.
I'm hoping that I could
switch all that around.
You know?
- Yeah.
- So, I don't know.
- Are there certain girls
that you frequent more often?
- I love Black girls.
- You like Black girls?
- I love my beautiful Black queens, man,
for some apparent... I'm
Spanish. I'm Colombian.
Latinas, I love my Latinas.
Don't get me wrong.
But, my Black girls, oh, they're just ahh!
- (laughs)
Do you ever play around with
some of the White girls
here? A lot of White girls.
- I haven't had the chance yet.
But I've messed around in Jersey
with a couple White
girls, all over the world.
You know, in Canada. I mean
it's, you know, really,
I don't judge. I don't discriminate.
But at the same time it's like
it's just science.
The blacker the berry,
the better the juice.
- That's what makes the world go around.
- Yeah, man.
- (mumbles)
- They say, "Once you go
Black you never go back,"
which is kind of true.
- Do the cops ever give you a hard time?
- Ooh, one time. I got caught
in Jersey picking up one.
It was the most embarrassing
thing in the world, man.
But, you know, it happens. We got over it.
It was a dismissed case. But...
- You had to go through it.
- I had to go through
it. And the embarrassment
I put my family through was even worse.
But, it's okay.
- So you're married or single?
- I'm single. Single dad.
- So you have a son or daughter?
- Yeah, I have a 14 year old daughter
who's onna be 15 in April.
- Okay.
You raised her?
- She's beautiful. I
raised her all the way.
She was 11 years old.
While the mother goes
to work in the morning,
I would go to the barber
shop in the afternoon.
So basically, she knows who her father is.
You know, anybody can be a dad.
She's a little bit mad at me right now.
But she'll realize it later on
why I did what I had to do, leave.
But I was with the mother of
my child 15 years. 15 years.
- And you prefer the
relationships you have
with these women, the
freedom that it provides?
- Yeah, because I don't really
have to answer to nobody.
You don't pay them to stay.
You pay them to leave.
And it's not that I'm having
sex with them all of the time.
Sometimes I just enjoy
the company. You know?
Sometimes, you know, you
never know why God puts,
or who God puts in your life
to change somebody else's life.
In my life it's been like,
it takes a complete perfect
stranger to make me look at
things differently in life.
And that's just spontaneous
things that happened in my life.
But I trust females more than
guys. So it's like I'd rather
be with like four or
five females in one night
than to be just hanging out with the guys.
Nah. It's cool, but
it's not really that...
I'm a horny mother fucker so it's like
I have to have sex all the time.
- So where do you take them?
You'll take them to a hotel or... ?
- To hotels, wherever they wanna go.
Sometimes outside.
I'll brain fuck them, actually, and
try to find out their fantasies and
accommodate to their fantasies. You know?
- But sometimes you're
doing it in the car?
- Yeah, I'll take them to a park.
- And you're using condoms?
- Oh yeah, all the time.
I'll stay with a condom.
Even with blow jobs. Rubber,
rubber, rubber, rubber.
That's the thing, girls.
You gotta protect yourselves too, man.
- Yeah.
- You know? Safe, safe,
safe, safe, safe, safe.
- What about drugs?
Are drugs part of the picture for you?
- Yeah, I do crystal meth.
- What does crystal meth do for you?
- It's like an aphrodisiac to me.
It feels good. Crystal meth, it just...
I start feeling like
Pepe Le Pew, Hugh Hefner, Benny Hill.
"Come here. Pepe Le Pew."
But yeah, it's more of
an aphrodisiac to me
than it is a stimulator.
Like a Red Bull times 10.
I don't start trippin'.
I'm like, you know, 'cause I
do drugs. I don't let it do me.
I'm still responsible. I work.
- Yeah, does it affect your job?
- Yeah. I love to hustle. I love hustling.
Hustle's what I love.
- The meth use doesn't get in the way?
- Doesn't affect me. No,
it actually keeps me awake
'cause I barely sleep.
And when I get sleepy
I do a little meth and I'll wake right up
like I'm ready to go.
One thing that Skid Row
has taught me is, you know,
being mature at my age.
Like, you never know.
I learned a lot from being here.
I've matured a lot too.
People here are just like,
they're awesome.
People here are awesome.
There's so much unity here
at the same time, but not
anybody is welcome here.
You have to really put in your
time to really get accepted.
Good people down here. Beautiful women.
It's nice.
I like the culture here. You know?
Life has been good to me, man.
I'm blessed being here and
getting to know different parts
of the world as I go along.
It's awesome. I plan on taking
my barber shop to a big level
that we all could just get
together and just collaborate
and just have a blast. Some
type of like Freaknik or like a
summer jam or like, you know,
pimp off parties or something.
You know, something
like that. All I know is
that I would like to throw
barbecues, parties, and
have everybody come. You're all welcome.
- Do you find you're
happier as a man who has
his choice of all these different women,
rather than being married to
one woman and being faithful?
- I do wanna find the
girl of my life because
once I start building
this dynasty, this empire,
I don't wanna do it by myself.
I need a partner next to me
so we could enjoy it together.
I might not have a female,
but as of right now I haven't found nobody
worthy enough of my time.
But I don't play with
nobody's heart either.
I treat them well. I try
to be polite and respectful
because it doesn't exist no
more. It's not cliche enough
for people to not like give a compliment.
Instead they're like,
(mumbles), downgraded.
I don't downgrade women, man.
I pick them up. I embrace
them.. I embrace everybody.
- That's great. The sex
that you have with them,
is it-
- Phenomenal.
- (laughs). You're doing
everything with them?
- Pretty much. It depends on who I'm with.
- Yeah.
- Depends. I prefer the
head without the ache.
I'm just a laid back guy. Just chill.
They can come to me with their problems.
They could talk about whatever they want
at that moment.
But then when they go
off, step outside my door,
they're on their own.
Hopefully, when they wanna go
to a happy place they think about me.
That's the impression
I wanna have on them.
- Yeah, it sounds like you're giving them
a nice break from what they're used to.
- Sometimes I don't
even have sex with them.
It's just there, talk. "What's up, girl?"
It depends on her spiritual
vibe, the vibe that we get.
There's some girls that are just...
See I try to find the beauty
in the most ugliest things.
But there's just some people
that are just ugly to the core.
And I still try to make them smile
with my little corny jokes
or whatever the case may be.
But, it's hard. They'll give
in eventually. They don't know.
They don't know what it
is to be loved. You know?
I don't know what it
is to be loved either,
but I'm looking for it and
I'll try to find out what it is
to be loved. You never know.
I might marry a porn star
or I might marry a
prostitute from the streets.
Who cares? I don't judge
them. It's only words.
They're human just like me, man.
- All right. Well,
Brian, thank you so much
for talking today.
- God's creation. Yeah, thank
you. Appreciate your time.
- Thank you for being so open and honest.
- Hey, man, that's all I know.
- Awesome. Thanks, man.